when your mom dies and you're in third
grade you might as well be an orphan i
mean
it's tough you know your mom is
everything right were you afraid that
your father
would just give you away or something
did you feel you just didn't know
i really didn't know now we lived back
to back with my father's sister
like the back of our house is matched up
so his sister lived behind us
so he kind of put me with my aunt right
and he continued to go to work
and uh you know try to continue his life
and then he passed
not long after that yeah your dad died
when you were 12. yeah
and i mean that is crazy now you're an
orphan at 12.
absolutely and i left my aunt's house
when i was 17 years old
now that made you a cool kid in the
sense that you were eligible for like a
social
security check because you had lost both
parents i assumed yes sir so you move
out and get your own place
yeah so you had absolutely no one
sitting there
spelling out rules for you you're really
on your own in the 12th grade i had my
own apartment can you imagine
in the 12th grade having your own place
was it party central i mean
it was yeah like what was going on in
that apartment that was back in the days
when you would get
weed and it would be like a bushel of
weed and it was the worst weed ever yeah
yeah and they would roll joints all day
and all night and stuff
and uh a lot i mean hey that's basically
how i ended up with my daughter
right you got a daughter and now you're
responsible for a young child and you've
got to make money
all of a sudden how old are you at that
point 18 yeah so then you figure out
i know what i'll do i'll join the
military yeah because you figured then i
can support my kid
absolutely and i and i i was like you
know what i got to do something
responsible i mean out here in the
streets running around
what if i go to jail right you know i'm
saying what if i go to jail
so i went in the army uh i went down and
uh
i just signed up and i basically went in
for uh
uniforms like i went in there and they
were like well
this one you get a 200 2500 bonus that's
infantry i'm like okay i'll do that
right and they go if you do airborne
you'll get a red beret but i'm like i'm
from a [ __ ] hood i can't come home in a
red beret
really right and so they said well if
you do this you're a ranger you get a
black beret i was like
black that's kind of dope like the
panthers that's that's gangster it's
true you almost want to kind of like go
in for the uh
uniform yeah you're not even thinking
about the reality i don't i don't even
know what these things are
then they said i said what's the green
beret they say well that's 52 weeks of
basic training that's
advanced individual training that's
special forces i'm like man that's too
long before i would get to my post
so i got rager qualified i went to darby
and
benning and jump and all that but even
the military you got in trouble you got
caught stealing a rug
and uh everybody said how is cern is
going to know all your [ __ ]
no i looked you up okay yeah i got the
fbi uh they did a full profile
no but seriously you got caught stealing
a rug and you were put military jail is
that a tough
scene i had this sergeant who who
realized some of us had special skills
right and he started asking for stuff
like i want this we need a bumper pool
table
and me and a couple of guys would go
around the post and
steal the [ __ ] and put it up in our area
and he thought it was cool so then he
got cocky he's like i want an infantry
blue rug
for my for my office and and
and i noticed there was one in the guest
house yes so
uh and you want to be the favorite to
your co right yeah
yeah he was a crook and so we went in
there with a box cutter cut a
big patch of the right dead out of the
it was a blatant crime right out of the
middle of the guest house
just ripped this thing out and we got
busted because
no one came to pick us up the guy was
supposed to pick us up where did he go
he flaked so we ended up having to put
it in the cab and the cab driver ratted
i got woke up by cid
it was a long story anyway what ended up
happening and i got
put in jail military jail yeah military
jail
but they made a mistake in the
prosecution of you
nah they gave me my 200 my 2 500
bonus while i was in jail that shows you
bureaucracy doesn't it
you're in military jail and they give
you a 2 500 bonus
cash cash you're like what i'm out of
this [ __ ] right so
so i planned and escaped and i uh
basically escaped from that jail
did you see any action when you were in
the military no nothing no just a lot of
training
right intense training is the training
good i mean did you learn a lot of stuff
yeah do you use that stuff out on the
street when you get out of the military
and you turn to a life of crime well you
know how to you know how to
to case a situation you know how to do
you know most of everything
is intelligence knowing what you're
going to get into prior to what you do
and uh just being on doing your numbers
being on time
all that kind of sync all that stuff
when one commits a crime
yeah uh and i'm talking about a crime i
guess you're armed and all that stuff
the getaway has to be planned perfectly
is that correct
getaway is more important than the
actual lit is that what you learned when
uh
you uh got caught with the rug in other
words your getaway was not solid
it was it sucked balls it got caught
yeah you know you gotta you know i mean
you can't walk into a spot and do
something and then walk out into the
street and say where am i gonna
go you know that's the plan and then you
say
getting this stuff is gonna be easy how
we get away
and you know i i wasn't much for being
arrested or incarcerated and stuff so i
by basically
i managed once i came home never to go
under again